[Applause]
[Music]
hey man how you doing here you guys got
bow and arrows
yeah yeah
oh yeah oh that's it yeah there it is
there that'll do it that's gonna do it
yup
where are the arrows at yeah you guys
got it mateys
we don't carry fireworks damn you have
uh you have something else that's
explosive that i could tape to the end
of an arrow
we have shotgun shells but i feel i have
to ask are you planning to attach those
to arrows and use them as a weapon
what no what are you crazy you think
that would work though
what if i shot explosive arrows through
a window to break them open
sir i feel like i have to ask you what
you're planning to use these for oh
i'm not planning to do anything i'm just
just christmas shopping you got zip
lines
nope but you got like hooks and anchors
and cables we got some of those things
but i do not recommend manufacturing
your own zipline oh
i'm not doing that no let's say somebody
was manufacturing their own zip zipline
do you think if they had busted some
windows open on a building somehow then
fired the zipline off a bow and arrow
and it attached to the wall of said
building that they could just ride the
zip line into the building
i have no idea sir whatever you're
planning on doing
please don't do it i'm not i'm not doing
anything i'm just doing some christmas
shopping trying to get it out of the way
you know bow and arrow's from her nephew
the zip lines from my
grandmother etc and whatnot you know
what i'm saying there it's
no big deal speaking of other things do
you guys have just the uh
top half of a knight in armor
first of all it's called a suit of armor
oh yep that's it that's right that's
what i meant to say
we have one but it's sold oh complete
set yep yep yep
yeah well the person is four they only
need to they don't need to they just
need the top half they don't need the
legs
well what if somebody was shooting at
you what were the chances you think
they'd try to shoot your legs
i feel like i have to tell you that a
suit of armor will not deflect
bullets i'll take my chair with
christmas
which brings me uh to my next question
do you guys have roller skates
i think we have a pair around uh-huh let
me ask you a question how fast do you
think you have to be going on roller
skates you get past a couple of arm
guards and still be going fast enough to
smash through a safe
door one of those big bank safes no
i don't i don't know yeah yeah
uh hey you guys got one of those you
know it's one of those big bags with a
dollar sign on the side of it
okay you're gonna shoot arrows with
shotgun shells attached to them to a
bank window to blow out the glass then
you're gonna shoot a zip line through
that window and you're gonna slide on
into the hallway
you're gonna be wearing roller skates so
you can just skate on past the armed
guards who will be shooting at you
and you're going to hope that they both
won't hit your legs and if they are
aiming at your torso the suit of
medieval armor will deflect the bullets
then you're going to hope to gather
enough speed to burst through the big
bank vault at the end of the hallway
where you're going to collect the money
in a cartoon
money bag
well no i'm just an uncle's wines for
christmas and i think i'll take my
business elsewhere
merry christmas it's april
you